.
Man kann sich heutzutage
vor "Wundermittelchen" kaum retten.
"Seit ich jeden Morgen Brunnenwasser
mit einer Viertel-Gurke trinke,
fühle ich mich viel fitter."
Vieles davon ist zum Verzweifeln,
aber, mein Gott, es kommt ja
niemand dabei zu schaden. Meistens.
Leider gibt es gefährliche Ausnahmen.
Darf ich vorstellen:
MMS - Miracle Mineral Solution.
Die Wunder-Minerallösung.
Der Name kommt nicht von ungefähr,
das Zeug soll alles Mögliche heilen:
Krebs, Autismus, Malaria.
Und man kann es ganz einfach und
rezeptfrei im Internet bestellen.
Was steckt dahinter?
Freunde der Sonne,
setzt euch, holt euch einen Tee,
denn den werdet ihr heute brauchen
für eure Nerven.
Hallo, Freunde der Sonne,
ich bin's wieder, Mai,
eure Chemikerin des Vertrauens.
Ich werde in den Kommentaren
immer wieder nach MMS gefragt.
Und ich habe tatsächlich
durch eure Kommentare
selbst zum 1. Mal davon gehört.
Warum ich jetzt ein ganzes Video
darüber machen muss,
dass werdet ihr gleich sehen.
Die Basics zuerst:
Die "Miracle Mineral Solution"
besteht aus 2 Teilen.
1.: ein Salz namens Natriumchlorit.
Natriumchlorit
ist übrigens nicht zu verwechseln
mit unserem geliebten Kochsalz
Natriumchlorid.
Zum Vergleich: Natriumchlorid
und Natriumchlorit.
Zweitens braucht man
eine Säure zum Aktivieren.
Aktivieren heißt:
Natriumchlorit und Säure reagieren.
Es entsteht eine Verbindung
namens Chlordioxid.
In der chemischen Industrie
ist das eine gängige Reaktion,
um Chlordioxid frisch herzustellen.
Aber man kann Chlordioxid auch
als bereits fertige Lösung kaufen,
was in der MMS-Nutzer-Szene
als CDL abgekürzt wird.
Chlordioxid
ist ein starkes Oxidationsmittel.
Heißt: Es eignet sich
hervorragend als Bleichmittel
oder als Desinfektionsmittel.
Von meinem Video zur "Tide Pod
Challenge" wisst ihr vielleicht,
dass Waschmittel
Oxidationsmittel enthalten,
um Verfärbungen und Schmutz
zu bleichen, sprich zu zerstören.
Doch Oxidationsmittel
sind meist nicht besonders selektiv.
Heißt: Sie zerstören alles Mögliche,
zum Beispiel Textilfarben, Fasern,
weswegen in Feinwaschmitteln z.B.
kein Bleichmittel enthalten ist.
Chlordioxid ist auch ein viel
einsetzbares Oxidationsmittel.
Als klassisches Bleichmittel kommt
es beim Papierbleichen zum Einsatz.
Es kann aber auch Bestandteile
von Zellen, z.B. Proteine "bleichen",
sodass man es einsetzen kann,
um Bakterien und Keime zu töten,
also als Desinfektionsmittel.
In geringen Konzentrationen benutzt
man es zur Trinkwasser-Desinfektion,
in höher konzentrierten Lösungen
benutzt man es zur Desinfektion
von Laborgeräten oder Oberflächen.
Oder eben nicht als Lösung,
sondern als Gas zur Gebäudereinigung
von verschimmelten Gebäuden z.B.
Denn das Gas
kommt dann z.B. überallhin,
wo man sonst nicht
so leicht hinkommt.
In den USA wird Chlordioxid
z.B. auch zur Desinfektion
von Hühnchen verwendet,
Stichwort Chlorhühnchen.
Okay, so weit so normal.
Das Ungewöhnliche ist,
dass dieses Zeug
nicht nur zum Bleichen
und Desinfizieren gut sein soll,
sondern auch
ein medizinischer Heiliger Gral.
Alles fing 1986 an mit einem
Amerikaner namens Jim Humble.
Schauen wir uns das genauer an.
Jim Humble,
Anhänger der Scientology-Sekte,
war nach eigenen Angaben im Dschungel
unterwegs mit ein paar Mitreisenden,
als sie an Malaria erkrankten.
Er hatte angeblich
die spontane Eingebung,
dass sein mitgebrachtes
Wasserdesinfektionsmittel
bestimmt gegen Malaria hilft.
Und prompt heilte er
angeblich seine Mitreisenden
und später auch sich selbst.
Dann gründete er seine eigene Sekte,
in der er MMS und andere "Medizin"
kurzerhand zu heiligen Sakramenten
erklärte. True story.
Jim Humble behauptet,
mit MMS zehntausende Menschen
geheilt zu haben.
Jim Humble ist nicht der Einzige,
der auf MMS und CDL schwört.
Es gibt dazu Bücher von verschiedenen
Autoren, auch in Deutschland.
Darin wird akribisch beschrieben, wie
man das Bleichmittel schlucken soll.
Warte mal, das kennen wir doch.
Aber nicht nur das,
man kann sich auch damit einreiben,
darin baden oder
als rektalen Einlauf benutzen.
Bitte was?
Ja, rektaler Einlauf. Man soll sich
das Ding in den Hintern spülen.
Alter...
Helfen soll es gegen alles:
von Fußpilz über Krebs bis Ebola.
Ja, Ebola.
Natürlich
auch bei Tieren und Kindern.
Beweise für eine derartige Wirkung
gibt es wohlgemerkt keine.
"Ich bekomme immer wieder zu sehen,
dass wissenschaftlich orientierte
Menschen kommen und sagen:
Wo sind die Beweise?
Und natürlich: Beweise können
wir so nicht liefern." - Bitte was?
In Facebook-Gruppen
tauschen sich MMS-Anwender aus.
In der größten
deutschsprachigen Facebook-Gruppe
waren bis vor Kurzem
34.000 Mitglieder.
2018 schloss Facebook
diese größte Gruppe
mit Verweis
auf die Gemeinschaftsstandards,
wo drinsteht, dass man
keine Aktionen unterstützen darf,
bei denen Leute verletzt werden.
Trotzdem gibt es heute noch
mehrere solcher Gruppen
mit tausenden Mitgliedern.
Okay, seid ihr bereit
für the real shit?
Selbstverständlich gilt:
Nur weil ein Stoff industriell
zum Bleichen verwendet wird,
heißt das nicht automatisch,
dass eine geringere Konzentration
nicht medizinisch genutzt werden
könnte. Die Dosis macht das Gift.
Es gibt sogar medizinische
Anwendungen von Chlordioxid.
Z.B. zum Desinfizieren
der Zitzen von Kühen nach dem Melken,
damit sie sich nicht entzünden.
Oder man kann es auch als
desinfizierendes Mundwasser nutzen.
Beides sind aber nur oberflächlich
desinfizierende Anwendungen.
Man schluckt das Mundwasser ja nicht.
Und in geringeren Konzentrationen
ist es, wie gesagt,
auch zum Desinfizieren
von Trinkwasser safe.
Zumindest gibt es da einen Grenzwert,
den Wasserwerke einhalten müssen
und der vor Schäden schützt.
Aber in den Büchern und
auf den Websites und in den Foren
wird was ganz anderes empfohlen:
100-1000 Mal höhere Dosen.
Und das soll angeblich
kein Problem sein. Hier steht z.B.:
"Eine konzentrierte MMS-Lösung
kann dunkle Stoff bleichen,
eine handelsübliche
Chlordioxid-Lösung
erreicht diesen Effekt
jedoch niemals."
Tja, unser maiLab-Redakteur Lars
hat diese handelsübliche
Chlordioxid-Lösung
experimentell nachgeprüft.
Dabei kam raus: Nicht nur bleicht
0,3 prozentige Chlordioxid-Lösung
sehr stark, auch Verdünnungen davon,
so wie sie zur Einnahme
empfohlen werden,
entfernten ein Stück Stoff.
"MMS ist keine Bleiche".
* Warnton *
Wenn ein Oxidationsmittel
so einen Stoff bleichen kann,
dann kann es auch biologisches Gewebe
zerstören. Das ist einfach Fakt.
Doch die Leute,
die mit MMS oder CDL Geld verdienen,
haben sehr kreative Argumente,
um diesen Fakt zu verschleiern.
Und das Ärgerliche ist: Sie sind
wirklich verdammt gut darin,
wissenschaftlich zu klingen.
Schauen wir uns
ein paar konkrete Beispiele an,
wie MMS- oder CDL-Experten Bullshit
als Wissenschaft verkaufen.
Eine wichtige Behauptung ist,
dass Chlordioxid
zwar Bakterien und Viren angreift,
aber menschliches Gewebe nicht.
Ihr kennt doch vielleicht aus dem
Bio-Unterricht "oxidativen Stress".
Der beschreibt, wie Zellen durch
Oxidationsmittel geschädigt werden.
Von Antioxidantien habt
ihr bestimmt auch schon gehört.
Die sind deshalb so gesund, weil
sie Zellen vor Oxidationen schützen.
Und obwohl jedem Chemiker diese
Basic-Redox-Chemie glasklar ist,
kommen die MMS- oder CDL-Gurus daher
und bombardieren die Leute
mit chemischen Möchtegern-Fakten.
Da werden Redox-Potenziale
rausgekramt, Zahlen genannt.
Okay, es ist hier völlig sinnlos,
dem Körper
ein Redox-Potenzial zuzuordnen.
Das ist ungefähr so,
als würde ich der Stadt Berlin eine
Körpergröße von 1,61 Meter zuordnen.
Das stimmt halt einfach nicht.
Das ist so frech.
Da werden grundlegende chemische
Zusammenhänge einfach ge... * Piep *
Denn Oxidationsmittel
schaden biologischen Zellen,
egal ob die von Bakterien
oder von Menschen sind.
Hier sind jetzt typische
Redox-Prozesse in einer Zelle.
Und all diese Stoffe können
von Chlordioxid oxidiert werden.
Übrigens ist auch Sauerstoff
ein Oxidationsmittel,
nur dass unser Körper mit Enzymen
perfekt damit umgehen kann.
Chlordioxid hingegen
macht einfach alles kaputt.
Das Einzige, was sie hier zeigt, ist,
dass es noch stärkere Oxidations-
mittel gibt als Chlordioxid.
Aber Chlordioxid reicht völlig aus,
um Zellen zu schädigen.
Was sich hier macht,
das ist eine Scheinbegründung,
eine verwirrende Ablenk-Technik.
Das ist so als ob ich sage:
Bananen sind gelb,
deswegen machen Bananen impotent.
Dann kann jeder sehen,
dass die Argumentation Quatsch ist.
Wenn ich aber sage:
Bei Bananen bestimmt das Verhältnis
von Carotinoid zu Chlorophyll
die Intensität der Lumineszenz
im ultravioletten elektromagnetischen
Spektrum. * Husten *
Deshalb machen Bananen
ganz eindeutig impotent.
Dann hat man als Nichtchemiker
keine Chance mehr durchzublicken.
Und deshalb
ist diese Taktik geradezu genial.
Aber lasst euch nicht verarschen.
Wir werden auch
gleich noch sehr grafisch sehen,
dass Chlordioxid sehr wohl
menschliches Gewebe verätzt.
Neben diesen klassischen
Chemie-Ablenkungsmanövern
werden auch immer wieder Studien
von den "Experten" hinzugezogen.
Manche dieser "Studien" sind schlicht
und einfach keine wissenschaftlichen,
um es mal höflich auszudrücken.
Dazu kommen wir noch gleich.
Andere Studien,
die wirklich wissenschaftlich sind,
werden einfach falsch ausgelegt.
Diese Studie
wird z.B. sehr gerne zitiert:
"Dr.Norio Ogata in Japan, der hat
ganz kleine Mengen nur gegeben.
Das war eine Menge
von ganz wenig Chlordioxid.
Und er hat zwei Mäusegruppen gehabt.
Die eine Mäusegruppe
wurde mit Vogelgrippe infiziert,
die extrem tödlich ist.
Von der normalen Kontrollgruppe
dieser Vogelgrippe
sind 70 % gestorben.
Von der Gruppe, wo in der Luft eine
ganz kleine Menge Chlordioxid ist,
haben alle überlebt. 100%.
Und das ist ein Fakt."
* Applaus *
Ja, die Luft wurde mit geringen
Mengen Chlordioxid versetzt,
um zu testen,
ob das Chlordioxid schon ausreicht,
um die Viren zu töten.
Und das haben sie gezeigt.
Das ist eine tolle Anwendung
von Chlordioxid, keine Frage.
Also so geringe Mengen
in die Luft zu bringen,
dass sie uns noch nicht schaden, aber
ausreichen, um Viren zu töten, super.
Es bringt aber nichts,
den Mäusen Chlordioxid
als Medikament zu verabreichen,
sei es vor oder nach der Infizierung.
Ein Oxidationsmittel wie Chlordioxid
ist relativ unselektiv
und relativ reaktiv.
D.h.: Sobald es etwas trifft,
was es oxidieren kann,
reagiert es sich ab.
Und beide Sachen sind danach futsch.
Das Oxidationsmittel ist abreagiert,
das andere Zeug ist oxidiert. Fertig.
Das bedeutet: Wenn Chlordioxid
zuerst auf Viren trifft,
oxidiert es zuerst die Viren.
Wenn es zuerst auf eine Maus trifft,
oxidiert es zuerst die Maus.
Das Beste,
was ihr passieren kann, ist,
dass die Konzentration so gering ist,
dass es der Maus nichts ausmacht.
Aber dieses Ding ist kein Medikament!
Es ist und bleibt ein Desinfektions-
mittel oder Bleichmittel.
Unter dem Deckmantel
angeblicher Wissenschaft
werden die Anwender
schlicht und einfach verarscht.
Und sie leiden darunter.
"Übelkeit, Erbrechen, Durchfall".
Aber keine Sorge: Wenn man erbricht,
sei das nur ein Zeichen,
dass es wirkt.
Wie sollen sonst die toten Bakterien
den Körper verlassen?
Für diese Idee Bakterienkotzen
wird ein weiterer wissenschaftlicher
Begriff zweckentfremdet,
nämlich die "Herxheimer Reaktion".
Das ist eine Reaktion des Körpers auf
freigesetzte Bakterienbestandteile,
allerdings vorwiegend
bei ganz bestimmten Bakterien,
bei "Spirochäten".
Die meisten Krankheitserreger gehören
wohlgemerkt nicht zu dieser Gruppe.
Außerdem verursacht
die Herxheimer Reaktion
typischerweise andere Symptome,
nämlich Fieber und Schüttelfrost,
ähnlich wie bei einer Grippe,
nicht Erbrechen und Durchfall.
Erbrechen ist hier nur die Reaktion
des Körpers auf Bleichmittel.
Okay, aber ehrlich gesagt:
Ich würde auch Kotzen in Kauf nehmen,
wenn ich dadurch
meinen Krebs heilen könnte.
Deswegen schauen wir doch mal, gegen
was MMS und CDL alles helfen soll.
Wir haben ja
schon einige Krankheiten genannt,
aber schauen wir uns
doch mal die vollständige Liste an:
* Klassische Musik *
Da schlägt mein Bullshit-O-Meter
schon direkt aus.
Kein Medikament dieser Welt kann
gegen so viele Krankheiten helfen.
So etwas gibt es nicht.
Abgesehen davon,
dass es für diese Heilkräfte
keine wissenschaftlichen Belege gibt,
soll es sogar gegen Krankheiten
helfen, die es gar nicht gibt.
Selbst wenn ihr gesund seid,
solltet ihr MMS nehmen,
denn ihr werdet
mirakulöserweise herausfinden,
dass ihr von Parasiten befallen seid.
Okay, das Ganze
funktioniert folgendermaßen:
Man schluckt MMS
oder verpasst sich das als Einlauf,
regelmäßig,
über einen längeren Zeitraum.
Irgendwann wird man dann
aufs Klo gehen und feststellen,
dass da komische Sachen rauskommen.
Das ist nämlich,
so viel zu "das Zeug schadet
keinem menschlichen Gewebe",
Darmschleimhaut,
die abgesondert wird.
Was auch ganz normal ist,
wenn der Darm
mit Bleichmitteln misshandelt wird.
Und in diesem Schleimhaut-Stücken
glauben Menschen Parasiten zu sehen.
Unsere Kollegen von "Kontraste"
zeigten solche Fotos
einem Internisten, der bestätigte:
"Das ist die Schleimhaut,
die sich abgelöst hat,
mit entsprechendem Schleim.
Auf dem einen Bild
sind sicher auch Blutanteile.
Das ist eine massive Schädigung
des Darmes."
Schuld an diesem Glauben
sind Menschen wie Kerri Rivera.
Sie steht als "Expertin" für die Idee
hinter diesen Parasiten.
Als "Beweis" hat sie u.a.
eine "Studie" von diesem Typ hier,
von Prof. Dr. Alex Volinsky.
Er ist zwar
eigentlich Maschinenbauer,
hat aber mal die DNA von so einem
Parasiten-Gewebestück analysiert,
um zu beweisen, dass dieses Gewebe
kein menschliches Gewebe ist,
sondern irgendeine Parasiten-DNA.
Tja, turns out:
Es ist menschliche DNA.
So sagen es ihm sogar seine Kollegen,
die, die sich damit auskennen:
Das scheint ihn nicht zu überzeugen.
Der hat seine ganz eigenen Fragen:
Wie gesagt:
"Das ist die Schleimhaut,
die sich abgelöst hat."
Dass der sich nicht schämt,
sich irgendwo hinzustellen
und so einen Vortrag zu halten.
Von MMS-Experten
wird so ein Bullshit natürlich
mal wieder als Wissenschaft verkauft.
Ha, gewitzt formuliert,
das muss man hier sehr wörtlich
nehmen, Freunde der Sonne.
Mehr als eine Meinung ist das nämlich
nicht, eine richtig dumme.
Besonders tragisch ist die Behandlung
von Kindern mit Autismus
durch verzweifelte Eltern.
Natürlich sollen Chlordioxid-Anläufe
auch gegen Autismus helfen.
Klar,
Leute wie Kerri Rivera behaupten,
dass Autismus auch nur
durch Parasiten ausgelöst wird.
Sie redet den Eltern ein,
dass sie ihren Kindern
diese Heilung vorenthalten,
wenn sie nichts gegen die Parasiten
in den Körpern ihrer Kinder tun.
Manche Eltern beobachten
sogar eine "Verbesserung" und sagen:
Ihre Kinder zeigten
weniger autistisches Verhalten.
Im besten Fall haben die Kinder
einfach etwas dazugelernt
und ihr Verhalten geändert.
Im schlimmeren Fall
checken die Kinder,
dass bestimmtes Verhalten
mit Einläufen bestraft wird
und versuchen
das Verhalten zu unterdrücken.
MMS hat keine wissenschaftl.
nachgewiesenen Heilwirkungen,
aber dafür gut nachgewiesene
schädliche Nebenwirkungen.
Die Frage ist:
Pass auf, der Witz ist:
Es geht gar nicht so vielen besser.
Die Foren sind voll von Menschen,
denen es von MMS, wie zu erwarten,
total schrecklich geht.
Doch daraufhin werden sie nur
angefeuert, es weiter zu nehmen.
Kein Wunder, den genauso
schreiben es ja auch die "Experten".
"Wir haben beobachtet, dass einige
Menschen eine extreme Abneigung
gegen MMS I entwickeln, während
sie die Behandlung durchführen.
Manchmal ist das so schlimm,
dass sie diese Dosis einfach
nicht mehr einnehmen können.
Ich glaube,
dass es dafür eine Erklärung gibt.
Möglicherweise erzeugen
die Krankheitserreger
die Aversion gegenüber MMS 1
als Schutzmechanismus,
um die Person davon abzubringen,
weiterhin das zu tun,
was sie zerstören könnte.
Wenn das auf Sie zutrifft,
sollten Sie wirklich alles versuchen,
um die Aversion
gegen MMS zu überwinden.
Es ist absolut wichtig,
dass Sie nicht ganz aufhören."
Fuck.
Noch mal: Es handelt sich hier
um ein oxidierendes Bleichmittel.
Die Lösung,
die Lars hier benutzt hat,
ist die gleiche, die autistischen
Kindern als Einlauf verpasst wird.
Mit dieser Konzentration konnte Lars
einwandfreie Batik-Shirts fertigen.
Ich hab natürlich
auch eines bekommen.
Und mit etwas höherer Konzentration
und einer Schablone kann man
richtig coole Drucke selbst machen.
Die Druck-Konzentration ist
immer noch deutlich weniger als das,
was manche freiwillig
selbst schlucken. Was tun wir jetzt?
Außer T-Shirts-Bleichen?
Teilt dieses Video.
Ich werde auch an dem Tag,
wo dieses Video online geht,
versuchen was auf Twitter zu starten.
Denn die Vernunft
muss sich stärker ausbreiten
als ein pseudowissenschaftlicher
Bullshit,
der Menschen dazu verleitet, sich
selbst und ihre Kinder zu verletzen.
Wenn ihr wütend seid,
glaubt mir, das bin ich auch,
dann macht eurem Ärger
gerne Luft in den Kommentaren.
Aber seid so gut und seid
keine arroganten Arschlöcher
und beschimpft MMS-Anwender
als dumm o.Ä.
Diese Menschen sind Opfer. Und sie
haben ein Recht auf Aufklärung
ohne angegriffen zu werden.
Den Opfern
kann ich das nicht übel nehmen.
Ich hab ja selbst gesehen,
wie diese "Experten"
z.T. mit Dr.- und Prof.-Titeln
mit diesen unglaublich clever
gemachten pseudo-wissenschaftlichen
Texten und Büchern und Fucking-
Redox-Potentialen daherkommen.
Ich versteh überhaupt nicht,
wieso so etwas überhaupt erlaubt ist.
Alles was ich machen kann,
ist aufklären.
Deswegen wirklich danke,
dass ihr bis hierher geschaut habt.
Und als Belohnung gibt es
in der Endcard etwas Besonderes:
Untertitel:
ARD Text im Auftrag von Funk (2019)
Freunde der Sonne, hier
ist das mai-Lab-Team. - Yeah! - Huhu.
Wir 2 sind ja schon von Anfang an mit
dabei. Melanie ist unsere Grafikerin.
Und auch sonst hält sie mir
in vielen Dingen den Rücken frei.
Und seit Januar ist jetzt
auch noch Lars bei uns im Team.
Mai hat ihn aus dem Labor
weggeklaut. - So war das.
Ich bin Biologe,
stand bis vor Kurzem noch im Labor:
Neuro-Wissenschaft
und Schlafforschung.
Jetzt habe ich einen
noch cooleren Job gefunden,
nämlich bei Mai arbeiten.
- Das hast du schön gesagt.
Ich bin super dankbar,
dass mit Lars ein
2. Wissenschaftler mit im Team ist.
Wir haben doppelte
Recherche- und Nerd-Power.
Ich hoffe, ihr spürt und merkt
das dann auch bei den Videos.
Ich bin auch in den Kommentaren
immer mal zu finden.
Also ich helfe mit,
Fragen zu beantworten.
Wenn ihr einen Lars
in den Kommentaren findet,
es ist dieser Lars.
Was wir schon länger
nicht mehr hatten: Keks-Emojis!
Wer von euch da draußen weiß, woher
die beiden sich eigentlich kennen?
Ich sage so viel: Auf dem
Channel gibt es einen Hinweis.
Ihr müsst das am Upload-Tag
in die Kommentar-Spalte schreiben.
Wenn ihr es richtig habt,
bekommt ihr:
* Trommelwirbel *
ein Keks-Emoji!